[Music]
75 years ago this weekend saw the end of
britain's colonial rule of india the
nation of 340 million people was divided
creating two independent countries
muslim majority pakistan and hindu
majority india it's a moment in history
known as partition it triggered a
massive forced migration and left an
estimated two million people dead in
religious violence mts tayab looks at
how the trauma of the event still
affects south asians generations later
an unprecedented mass migration has
begun as millions of people make their
way across borders the consequence of a
century-long british strategy of divide
and rule never has the marvel cinematic
universe introduced viewers to a moment
in history quite like this
and transported one of its superheroes
on a journey of self-discovery to the
site of one of the largest and deadliest
mass migrations in modern human history
but that's exactly what the disney plus
limited series ms marvel does iman
valani plays gamalakhan a muslim
pakistani american teenager from new
jersey
who gains superpowers from a mysterious
bengal that once belonged to her
grandmother who disappeared during the
partition of british india 75 years ago
fatima oscar wrote the acclaimed episode
which tackles the painful history
head-on
why does what happened
in 1947 still resonate
so strongly with so many south asians
that when creating ms marvel the series
it became such a
big story arc there's so much silence
that has been around partition right
there's silence that the west has had
around partition but there's also
silence in south asian communities and
the south asian diaspora around
partition in part it's because it's such
a traumatic
um event we've become increasingly more
aware
trauma lives in the body and it's passed
down through generations and so
we can feel some of this pain even if we
don't have words for it generational
trauma is central to ms marvel's origin
story like in this poignant scene
between kamala and her grandmother
portrayed by legendary pakistani film
actress samina ahmed
i'm still trying to figure out who i am
my passport is pakistani my roots are in
india
and in between all of this
there is a border
there is a border marked with blood and
pain
those borders were drawn in just five
weeks by a british civil servant who had
never traveled further east than paris
or understood india's religious
linguistic and cultural diversity after
two centuries of brutal colonial rule
britain's exit from the colony it
plundered such a vast fortune from
quickly turned into a bloodbath fleeing
from their looted bloodstained towns
comes a new exodus it's estimated up to
two million people were killed and
around 20 million were displaced as they
tried to make their way to what became
muslim majority east and west pakistan
or hindu majority india
by 1858
the crown ruled all of india a painful
past other south asian creatives want
people to better understand
at london's british film institute is
child of empire an animated virtual
reality journey through partition which
follows the stories of two characters
making opposite journeys across the new
borders
irfan sadati and sparshahuja created the
project partition was 75 years ago
why
does this story matter today
we still talk about the holocaust the
world war ii or the armenian genocide as
things that continue to be to be part of
lived world history
i think partition in the same manner is
the defining moment of modern south asia
the other reason why we don't want to
leave partition in the past is that the
united kingdom tends to see partition as
south asian history when it is
very much british history
in the three quarters of a century since
independence tensions between india and
pakistan have boiled over into four wars
a nuclear arms race and the creation of
bangladesh in 1972 as a new generation
tries to reckon with the pain of
partition through art fatima oscar hopes
it will lead to a more unified future
when you look at an event like partition
and you see even 75 years later that
things like that are happening today
you're like this is important like this
is why we need to actually break some of
these silences to contend with our
history to deal with our pain and to
create these lines of solidarity so that
we can actually protect each other do
you know what you are for cbs saturday
morning in kyoto london i'm a superhero
wow so important well it's still
stunning to hear the numbers two million
people estimated to have died yes 20
million
displaced in the partition incredible
number and as she said you keep seeing
it happen over and over in history
and people don't know about it which is
why it's so important like pieces like
this to be done so we know it is a part
of your past it's a part of your future
generations